Doing keto, it's tempting to buy plant-based dairy products to take the place of real dairy, such as cream cheese, cheese, yogurt, etc.
But looking at these ingredients in these plant-based substitutes, they look a little bit like fracon foods, isolates, gums, etc.
Is it better to void these altogether or are all these additives relatively harmless?
Well, I would say some are relatively harmless, some of the gums and some of the other different substitutes that they use.
You can develop antibodies again so that you could have sensitivities to it, but some of the fibers and stuff that they use are relatively harmless.
You'd have to look up each ingredient. Obviously, it's much better to eat real dairy or, you know, but we're trying to stay up, you're on a dairy-free diet, you can't do that.
So just stay away from some of those things are probably the best.
As far as yogurt, like there's coconut milk, yogurt's out there that I think are just fine.
You know, most of the dairy yogurt that you find out there, unless you're getting it organic, is got a bunch of additives and garbage.
Most of the dairy products, unless you're getting it clean, dairy, clean organic or from the farm or something like that, it's going to have a bunch of garbage in it as well.
So just because it's dairy doesn't mean that it's necessarily going to be good for us either.
So there's a lot of nasty stuff even in what we would term as real food as well.